un bon soir contre blanche et son expert
en relations internationales tout
d'abord pourquoi cette décision de la
cour constitutionnelle allemande et des
fermes attendus
elle était très attendue parce que comme
vous venez de lire c'était un préalable
à la ratification par l'allemagne de ce
plan de relance dans lequel la
chancelière merkel avait dépensé
beaucoup d'énergie beaucoup de savoir
faire et il était très attaché si la
cour constitutionnelle de karlsruhe
avait décidé aujourd'hui que ce plan
n'était pas conforme à la constitution
eh bien ça aurait été la fin de ce plan
et la fin du plan de relance européen
par conséquent un gros échec pour madame
merkel à trois mois d'élections qui vont
probablement amener un nouveau
chancelier ou nouvelles sur seulles hier
puisque madame merkel n'est pas
candidate
donc l'enjeu est très important
politiquement pour le gouvernement
allemand est aujourd'hui la voie est
ouverte
18 pays ont ratifié ce plan les autres
vont suivre
peut-être y aura-t-il encore quelques
difficultés avec la hongrie et la
pologne
mais on a on a l'habitude et madame
merkel à chaque fois a réussi à
surmonter ses difficultés avec ces deux
pays qui ne veulent pas que l'on
conditionne l'octroi de crédits à des
conditions de respect des droits de
l'homme
donc on a fait un progrès considérable
puisque avec cette ce plan la commission
est autorisé à lever un emprunt de 500
milliards d'euros
et c'est la première fois que la
commission est autorisée afin à lever un
emprunt sur le marché des capitaux et en
deuxième lieu le 2e deuxième percée
c'est le fait que les états percevront
des concours de ce fonds en fonction de
leurs besoins tels qu'ils ont été
établis en fonction de leur population
en fonction des dommages causés par le
coc u19 et qu' ils rembourseront avec un
très grand différé
près de vingt ans de différé en fonction
de leurs clés budgétaire c'est donc en
effet une mise en commun d'une partie de
la dette des états manquent c'est donc
une percée tout à fait importante et
c'était inimaginable il ya un peu plus
d'un an
alors claude quand la france parce que
c'est la question évidemment c'est ce
que beaucoup attendre conteste que la
france va-t-elle profiter de ce plan de
relance âprement négocié alors le plan
tel qu'il a été négocié prévoir se sait
les enveloppes dont bénéficieront les
divers états membres en fonction de
critères comme je viens de l'indiquer et
la france a tendance à recevoir 40
milliards d'euros au cours des années et
2021 et 2022
mais évidemment ça n'est pas un guichet
ouvert chaque état membre a été prié
d'élaborer un plan un plan de réforme un
plan d'action un plan d'investissement
et chacun de ses plans a fait l'objet de
discussions à bruxelles et le plan
français était présente et a été
approuvé en deuxième lieu compte tenu de
l'urgence
les états membres seront autorisés à
engager les dépenses sur ses plans
d'investissements sur ces actions qui
ont été approuvés à bruxelles
quitte à attendre pour se faire
rembourser que le plan sera totalement
mis en place parce que sur le sur le
plan des garanties juridiques et
financières est un petit peu compliqué à
mettre en place et que la commission
doit aussi répondre de contrôle de la
cour des comptes européenne et un
certain nombre de contrôleurs financiers
donc ça prendra un petit peu de temps je
pense que le conseil européen du 24 juin
se prononcera sur ce sujet demandera une
accélération de la mise en place
concrète et se penchera peut-être sur
les deux premiers buts derniers
problèmes résiduels et puis il est
possible aussi que la chancelière pour
qu'il se sera l'un des derniers conseils
européens voudra marquer encore une fois
l'histoire de l'europe en disant que
ça n'est peut-être pas suffisant on
verra leur à sa gestion des vaccins a
quelque peu écorné son image son plan
sera utile lui suffisant pour faire face
aux conséquences économiques de la
pandémie
alors effectivement si on compare aux
états unis ça fait un petit peu modeste
puisque joe biden a fait approuver le
mois dernier un premier plan de relance
qui se monte à 1900 milliards de dollars
donc ça fait à peu près 1500 milliards
d'euros mais c'est en effet à peu près
le double du plan du plan européen
cela dit pour faire une comparaison
équitable il faudra ajouter au plan
européen
les plans de relance purement nationaux
qui ont été mises en place ou qui sont
en train d'être mise en place
mais cela dit les américains aussi or
d'autres plans pour les infrastructures
qui sont actuellement discutées par le
congrès est en effet la relance
américaine est beaucoup plus massive que
ce qui se fait en europe
donc c'est un premier un plus premières
critiques que l'on peut faire peut-être
que l'europe ne voit pas assez grand
mais il fallait créer des instruments
qui sont maintenant créer en effet le
conseil européen fin juin peut tout à
fait décider qu'il faut aller plus loin
dans cette direction ou en 1re en
imaginant d'autres procédures pour ce
qui est des vaccins et bien l'europe et
est victime du fait qu' il y à peu d'une
usine de fabrication de vaccins sur le
territoire de l'union européenne
après tout beaucoup de ses capacités
industrielles sont en dehors du
territoire de l'union européenne et
viendra trop peu il faut longtemps à
porter deuxième élément c'est que les
états membres ont sans doute été trop
timide trop respectueux de l'accord
politique il avait passé pour se
coordonner à bruxelles mais l'union
européenne en tant que telle n'a pas de
compétence sanitaire elle à celle que
les états membres veulent bien lui
conférer par consensus et rien empêché
les états membres certains l'ont
d'ailleurs fait d'acheter des vaccins en
plus
des dotations européenne de les acheter
sur le marché mondial partout et de
faire homologuer ces vaccins par leurs
propres autorités sanitaires nationales
en attendant qu'ils ce qu'elle le soit
par l'autorité européenne des
médicaments
c'est notamment le cas pour les vaccins
russe puisque certains avaient à membres
souhaitent les utiliser tout de suite
sans même attendre l'autorisation de
l'agencé européenne des médicaments
merci claude blanchemaison on va avoir
été avec nous